[Music]
hello welcome to et I'm Sophie Scholl AC
and happy early Mother's Day in
celebration of Mother's Day all week we
are talking about all things motherhood
today we are talking about something
that is a very big challenge for me
personally naming your baby joining me
today is Aaron ziering
she is a co-founder of millennial mamas
and the wife of nano to know star ion
ziering welcome thank you for having me
thank you for being here so you have two
beautiful girls how old are they they
have a birthday David birthday seven and
five and their names are Mia and Penna
so the big question to start off with is
how did you choose their names our
naming situation was really intense
ein has a lot of opinions for one and he
also had special letters he wanted to
name the girls after his parents or the
passed away so his mother he wanted to
name my first child after and her name
was Muriel and eyen wanted an M name
didn't have to be her name but it had to
be an M name okay Mia was the only name
that we agreed on like he was so
opinionated he wanted Marlee so bad all
I could think about was the dog yeah I
can't name our kid after it was out at
the time that was the first thing that
came into my head - and it's been years
since that movie exactly okay so and
then tell me about patna panna was a
little more interesting I was given a
pea for his father Paul to meet her and
I could not think of anything I was not
feeling any of the pea names and I came
across the name Penn I really liked it
but it sounded a little masculine I
didn't want to give her a name that was
also could be a boy name so I needed
something feminine and my friend called
me she was on a trip and she was at the
river Penna and she said I came to her
in a dream and kind of gave her some
motherly advice and I said that's a
beautiful word I looked it up and pana
was about PE and HJ and I meant beloved
in Swahili but that was beautiful it
meant feather in Russian the way I
changed the spelling - and I just
such a beautiful name didn't know anyone
with it I don't think there is anybody
out there with that name in America
that's what about middle names um Mia
was just a haphazard what sounds good
with Mia and remembered so feel or add
me Lauren and we went with this we
actually did the name after a movie star
okay and then for panna my mother she's
like a fourth-generation Mei and she did
not give me that middle name because she
did not like her middle name and when I
use yeah I think it's okay pen ma yeah
kind of southern mellow fast and my mom
was not happy I don't like it got lots
of opinions when you tell people what
you're naming your job
oh yes and we're gonna come back to that
in a minute but first I want to talk
about the popularity of pop culture and
television celebrity inspired names now
believe it or not 902 100 is still
inspiring baby names today our friends
at names org recently did a study about
how many babies have been named after
those nine oh two one out characters
Dylan Brandon and Brenda were the
biggies but Steve did come in at number
four names for your hobby of course so
what is your take on naming kids after
TV characters I love it I mean Mia
definitely me Lauren and I would love to
give our child a name after we had a
third I would love to like give it one
of ions character even so we had a boy
it'd be so fun to name it Steve or Finn
the personal sharknado in there too yeah
but I love the 902 and onions are so fun
yeah it's super fun and friends is still
inspiring names today some of the ones
today that are really popular are Game
of Thrones there's aria Amelia Khaleesi
Maisie Tyrion Star Wars Luke Leia Lucas
Anakin even star and Han are inspiring
names which i think is so cool Disney's
always popular Ariel is still a biggie I
think that's so cool I nice the same
burial and I actually know two girls at
my daughter's dance class named Khaleesi
and Aria resumes I was like what that's
the coolest thing they name their
daughters after the game of Thrones
girls
okay real life yeah yeah I've met their
sisters so okay big fans they're our
sisters and they're both named Matt for
Game of Thrones yes how cute is that
okay now here is something that a lot of
parents grapple with do you tell people
ahead of time once you've chosen the
name you know I do cuz I can't keep my
mouth shut
anybody I told somebody Mia's name and
she looked at me and she went that's all
you could think of I was like ready the
day before I had her to go into the
hospital she's like oh that's all you
could think of huh
did that make you doubt it oh I was like
heartbroken I was at my first baby
hormone I went in the corner and cried
like oh my gosh I was gonna eat her name
she was like five Mia's in her classes
okay what about you are you gonna tell
us your baby names I'm thinking I'm
working on it the last name is boya
which is challenging to pair with so
with the last names earring were you
worried at all about matching it I feel
like a lot could go with yeah a lot
could go with it it was not a struggle
for us okay so it's a struggle for me
I'm working on it I like V names I guess
I like the alliteration so we'll see but
the problem is I feel like anything that
ends with an a gets sing-songy with boya
so I don't know we'll see it could be
fun it could be fun
yeah we got to find the right one now
before we wrap things up today tell me
about the work that you are doing with
millennial mama the millennial Mama's I
partnered with one of my best friends
and fellow bloggers being a crown home
and we've launched a collaboration site
together we both had different interests
but we found that both his mother's we
had so many similarities and we wanted
to find a way to bring more women
together to share our love of different
women and also host really fun things
we've been getting together we have
conversations about motherhood and share
a lot on our social medias and on our
blog so you can check us out so where
can people find you the millennial mom
is calm and on social media at the
millennial mamas amazing thank you so
much thank you for being here thank you
thank you so much for watching be sure
to stick with ET online.com for all
things Mother's Day happy Mother's Day
to you too